mathis une charge de vous montrer des
chroniqueurs quand il était enfant et il
y aussi à essayer de retrouver ne qu'il
s'agit alors regardez ça là c'est pas
trop difficile on va pour la première
mais elle y regarder c'est parti cki
salle s'est entraîné seul c'est qui ça
rock rally et géraldine maillet well
appauvrira dink ont embrassé quitte à
revenir dans un restaurant attention là
ça devient plus dur regardes et tu avais
l'air sympa les minois
elle a émis quelques notes bb à il est
mignon ouais c'était avant la guerre
pendant la guerre et on dirait que c'est
pour le bien des blues les gars des bons
gars des bons gars alors on va partir un
peu plus loin dans le temps regarder non
csb rebelles alors s'effondrer nord est
de londres et isabelle vous avez quel
âge à la j'avais j'étais en scène c'est
pour regarder mais regardez la prochaine
oh la la
[Musique]
on voit dia stade ils avaient de losail
à la maison il a passé on dirait
vraiment un truc il a été acheté et la
salopette et ils disent oui mes yeux
l'époque n'avait pas les yeux ouverts
que ça déjà les aime et les cheveux sont
magnifiques gd toulon ah ouais ouais
tout coup non on rigole toujours été
beau gosse à part les oreilles c'est
normal c'est la manière même année alors
attention cette vidéo de pin devrait
donc aller regarder cette photo la
regarder à ben brik et des fleurs on
dirait un candidat des chiffres et des
lettres
[Rires]
mais l'attaqué nasa j'avais 6 ans mais
on diffère en direct on a 42 ans semble
agacer un premier ministre suédois
mais c'est fait c'est sven ikea non mais
c'est pas du tout on vous dit qu'on
contre argent semble un gamin qui
viennent brouiller une grange on m'a dit
ah ouais vercoquin très coquin l'avait
d'ailleurs qu'au cas où il est toujours
il est resté qu aucun rêve ouvrir
attention regardez ça lasse normalement
c'est facile j'avais ont semblé toucher
pâquis à messi qui ressemble à quelqu'un
c'est bel et bien un truc que je valais
réel josy c'est valérie toujours sur
toutes les photos gérer quatre bananes
par du jeu auquel on revient tout de
même à beinheim le même sourire et la
qualité de cheveux il faudrait toujours
bien sûr à l'affranchi jeunesse
approaching à l'époque
et attention le dernier regarder a été
déjà michel amat la photo la voix
ces gens me va bien sûr yannick a été au
bout déjà
et oui y'a pas vous voulez vous je ne
retrouverai la kerou beach est mignon
bas et oui si tu ne m'aimes pas nous
dégoûte pas les autres celui là il n'en
revient pas bon y'a pas moi et je me
sens pas mal du tout